hello today we're going to give a peek
behind the vmsu launch on Google cloud
into our storage infrastructure my name
is Dean Hildebrand and I'm a technical
director for storage in the Google cloud
office of the CTO and I'm Dennis cerini
I'm the tech lead for Google Cloud
Storage alright so in this session we're
gonna answer a very simple question how
does Google clouds to Gale your storage
infrastructure and it actually has a
relatively simple answer so the first
key points and I really do think this is
a very important point is that there is
a single infrastructure that underpins
both Google services and Google cloud
and so Google cloud customers and
YouTube and Andrew play store services
scale for the exact same reason and
that's because they're using the exact
same underlying infrastructure and next
we're gonna dive into the details of
Colossus the file system that is at the
core of this scalability and talk about
how Colossus abstracts out the
complexities and messiness of the
physical infrastructure to provide a
highly performant cost-efficient storage
infrastructure for Google clouds storage
services so let's take a step back
what are cloud regions with 23 regions
and 70 zones working together so
seamlessly it's sometimes easy to forget
they're actually mapped down to a set of
groups of physical data centers and
what's in these data centers pipes lots
of pipes but actually ok there's a
little more as well there's also lots of
servers and storage because how else
you're gonna compute anything so it's
pretty straightforward though that when
you launch a VM let's say a 32 V CPU
skylake it ends up running on one of our
skylake machines and the operation of
this is pretty fascinating but one of
the questions I get a lot from customers
is how does our storage work how does
Google Cloud take our servers disks
networks and cobble them all together to
provide such a wide range of storage
services
and a typical follow-up question is does
Google use the same infrastructure as
Google cloud and of course the answer is
yes but how does this work so let's
cover that as well so in this talk we
wanted to give a peek behind the end
that you're launching to give some
insight into how we build our storage
systems here at Google so you can have
the confidence that your applications on
Google cloud can scale just like Google
services so to begin just like any
well-designed software system all of
Google is layered with a common set of
scalable services there are three core
building blocks used by each of our
storage services and they are Colossus
spanner and Borg and of course there's
many others but you know in the interest
of time let's focus on these big three
so first we have Borg which launches
everything from compute services to
storage services and everything in
between and as you probably many of you
already know much of the learnings
inside of Borg was all translated into
kubernetes when it launched second we
have spanner which is our globally
consistent scalable database that is
used by Google services as well as our
cloud customers as cloud spanner and
finally we have Colossus the beginnings
of which started as the Google file
system which inspired many open source
file systems such as HDFS but since that
time Google has scaled a lot and there's
a lot more data to store and so the need
for this higher level of scalability
really drove the creation of Colossus
and since this is a talk about storage
dennis is gonna go deep into the details
of Colossus in a few moments and so to
get back to this question of how it is
Google cloud operate our storage it uses
these three core building blocks to
provide the underpinnings for all of the
storage services that you see from
firestore at a cloud sequel to file
store and google cloud store
now let's also get back to the question
of whether Google uses the same school
infrastructure and how does it use it
and the answer of course is that yes it
does as I've stated already and it
doesn't in a pretty simple way in the
same way that the cloud does it it takes
each of the services that you see you
know from YouTube the photos takes these
same scalable building blocks and then
layers on top of all of their needs to
provide you know the level of
availability performance durability that
you're looking for in your storage
systems so this allows both Google
services and Google Cloud customers to
scale in the exact same way because
they're using the exact same set of
building blocks and so you know you can
have the confidence that if you go off
and watch Cobra Kai and there's also a
million other people that want to watch
Cobra Kai at the same time then these
three services are behind the scenes
scaling to meet the needs and
traditionally what's interesting is that
much of the use cases in Tuborg spanner
and Colossus and all of the innovation
in them was driven by the Google
services but as our cloud customers have
really scaled across the globe they are
now providing a lot of the innovation as
well so let's look at a typical flow
let's say a user launches a gke cluster
on to a series of servers so the VMS in
that cluster get launched onto a series
of the servers that they requested and
that's using Borg by the way and so then
these VMs running on those services in
the GK cluster access their favorite
storage services let's say they use
persistent disk for their boot volume
and then they used file store and Google
Cloud storage for their unstructured
data once they start accessing those
services the exact same big three
building blocks Colossus spanner and
Borg are underneath the covers providing
all of the services so Borg is
provisioning the resources for that
storage system spanner is storing the
metadata to say for example who can
access the data and where is the data
actually
gated and then colossus of course is
providing all storage for the data so
now that we understand these three basic
services for the rest of this talk let's
deep dive into cloud storage and how it
makes use of Colossus so from the user
point of view you know Google has spent
a lot of time and effort to try to make
cloud storage as easy to use as possible
you know we want it to be as easy as
Dylan up and emptying out and actual
byte but behind the scenes from Google's
perspective cloud storage is actually a
massive distributed system that has the
potential and take advantage of all of
our region's networks points of presence
and all the servers and disks that I
talked about earlier and it has to make
use of all those aspects to satisfy
three primary use cases content storage
compute analytics and machine learning
as well as backup and archiving and from
the cloud perspective we have lots of
customers in each of these areas that
are scaling using the services so for
example box is delivering a lot of
content to its users the Broad Institute
is constantly analyzing lots of
different genomes every day and the New
York Times you can find a really
interesting article about how it's using
Google Cloud Storage to archive its
entire photo history but Google Cloud
Storage can scale to meet these needs
because it's already been meeting the
needs of our Google cloud services such
as services such as YouTube ads and
photos which archives a lot the photos
so in this talk we've learned about how
Colossus is underpinning Google Cloud
storage and it provides support for
three very unique use cases and now I'm
going to turn it over to Dennis so he
can explain how it is Colossus achieve
all of this thanks Dean so we talked a
lot about GCS and how it can support a
very wide range of use cases from
archival storage to high-throughput
analytics but we don't talk a lot about
the system that lie
under GCSE Colossus which enables GCS is
unique capabilities so I'm gonna dive
into the details of how GCSE uses
Colossus and how Colossus works we'll
start from the top and work our way down
so I'm starting with the client library
which is how GCS interacts with Colossus
actually the client is probably the most
complex part of the system there's a lot
of functionality that goes directly in
there
for instance software raid and
applications can choose their own
encodings based on a platonic to fine
tune the performance cost trade-offs
that they need to make for different
workloads the foundation of Colossus is
its scalable metadata service called the
curator it scales because clients talk
to it only for control operations for
instance creating a file and because it
can scale out horizontally it can also
scale massively because it's built on
top of a no SQL database called like
BigTable in fact the original mode of
Google had for building Colossus was
that search was running into scaling
limits as Dean mentioned of its
predecessor the Google file system
putting filesystem metadata into
BigTable was the key trick that allowed
Colossus to scale up by over a hundred x
over the largest GFS clusters another
way the system scales is that Colossus
minimizes the number of hops for data on
the network data flows directly between
D servers which is are really not very
clever name for our simple network
detached disks and the Colossus client
finally Colossus includes background
storage managers called
custodians which handle things like disk
space balancing and raid reconstruction
they play a key role in maintaining the
durability and availability of data as
well as ensuring the storage system is
working
efficiently so that's Colossus in a
nutshell here's a picture of what a
typical Google cluster looks like the
key ingredient is having the shared
storage pool managed by the Colossus
control plane this large disaggregated
storage layer is able to support a wide
variety of applications on the same
underlying physical resources and each
application has the rough illusion of
having an isolated filesystem in
aggregate we're talking about really big
scale here a single cluster is scalable
to the exabytes of storage with tens of
thousands of machines and what I've
drawn here represents a typical mix of
internal Google services you've got some
YouTube serving and maybe some ads
mapreduces together with GCP VM
instances using GCS all together sharing
the same underlying Colossus file system
so it's really the case that the same
storage system that's driving these
global scale Google applications is also
driving our customers cloud workloads
the scale disaggregation of resources
and variety of workloads is the key to
driving efficiency and lowering costs
for instance we can provision to the
peak demand of low latency workloads
like maybe this YouTube serving workload
here and then run batch workloads like
mapreduces and other analytics more
cheaply by having them fill in the gaps
of otherwise idle time another great
thing about Colossus is it abstracts
away a ton of complexity that storage
intensive applications would otherwise
have to deal with for one thing frankly
our data centers have a tremendous
variety of underlying storage hardware
when we're adding capacity to the system
we're always buying the disk of the day
which is whatever disk currently has the
lowest total cost of ownership and the
same goes for flash and these devices
last a long time which means that each
cluster will have many disk sizes and
types add to that the
that applications have different
requirements around durability
availability and latency Colossus
addresses that by providing service
tiers and allowing applications to
specify erasure codes tuned to their
needs and add to that at Google scale
some hardware is failing virtually all
the time that's just a testament to the
scale that we're operating at it's not
like the hardware is unreliable it's
just that there's a lot of it so dealing
with some failures is the common case
Colossus tears i/o around these failures
and does fast background recovery to
provide highly durable storage within
the cluster despite all of this chaos
the end result is that for GCS as well
as Google's own services these Hardware
resources and their associated
complexity are totally abstracted away
systems provision bytes and i/o as
abstract undifferentiated units that
makes using storage very simple for all
the applications were running so now
let's deep dive into how Colossus helps
ensure the storage pool is being managed
efficiently I mentioned that
applications built on top of Colossus
can provision bytes and i/o as abstract
resources but as you might imagine it
involves a lot of magic to ensure that
all the i/o and all the bytes are
available when applications need them
but also not over provision either of
these things because that would mean a
lot of waste under the hood we take
advantage of the fact that data has a
wide variety of temperatures as we're
trying to illustrate here we mix in
flash not always to lower latency but
simply because flash is the most
efficient way to serve really hot data
if we do our job right we buy just
enough flash to push the i/o density per
gigabyte into for the remaining data
into the range that can be served by
disks and then we buy just enough disks
so that we can fill them all up if we do
this well
and have the right mix we end up with
really efficient storage now let's talk
about how colossus maximizes storage
efficiency for disk-based storage within
our population of disks as I mentioned
earlier we're gonna have a wide variety
of disk sizes to maximize efficiency
we'll want to do two things we'll want
to keep the disks full cuz empty bytes
are just excess inventory and we want to
keep the disks busy so we're not wasting
that disk spindle because each cluster
has this roughly the same IO bandwidth
what this means is that sorry because
each disk has roughly the same IO
bandwidth what this means is that we'll
have to keep hotter data evenly spread
across all the drives in the cluster and
then we just fill up all the remaining
space on each drive with cold bytes to
make this work the key problem that
Colossus has solved is placing data
intelligently turns out newly written
data is typically hotter so Colossus
spreads new writes evenly across all the
disks leading to a pretty even balance
of hot data and then Colossus as
background rebalance er moves older cold
data to bigger drives this works great
for analytics workloads because
analytics data typically cools off as it
ages now a lot of this stuff was
developed and refined over the years so
that Google can run its own services
search ads YouTube etc all those
services that Dean was talking about at
massive scale as simply and efficiently
as possible
but for cloud this means that cloud
users can also leverage this
functionality and you end up with simple
and inexpensive storage okay so this is
a picture of one of our internal
dashboards used to monitor and debug
storage performance in a cluster there's
a lot of boxes in this visualization
each of those small boxes is a D server
and their size by dis capacity and
colored by spindle utilization
looks like this we're really happy
basically the whole cluster is really
busy that's why it's looking all red
like that so we're getting all the value
out of our disk spindles sure there's
some darker color sprinkled in there but
it turns out those are d servers that
are down for maintenance are being
decommissioned
so that's Colossus in a nutshell
now let's pop the stack and talk about
GCS itself which is really just a layer
on top it turns out GCS is employing a
lot of the same tricks that Colossus
uses just at the region and multi region
level to illustrate how they're similar
here's a simple representation of a GCS
deployment in one of our DCP regions in
this example we've got three clusters
each with a GCS instance on top of
Colossus storage first off GCS employs
some of the same hot data placement
techniques used by Colossus placing data
close to where it's likely to be read
and also caching data to minimize
network distance and lower latency and
just like Colossus is rebalancing colder
data within the cluster GCS rebalances
colder data between clusters in the
region to make sure we're able to fully
utilize all available space as well as
ensuring that data is always durable and
available in the face of disruptions or
failures in the underlying
infrastructure GCS kind of thinks of
each cluster in Google's fleet as an
abstract disk and by managing these
clusters intelligently it's able to
handle all the diverse workloads that
users bring to GCS like content serving
and our archival and analytics and do it
efficiently the way we think of GCS is
that it's Colossus in the cloud so to
wrap up we know about GCP scalability
what we uncovered today is that GCP can
scale because it's built on top of
core Google services that are battle
tested and have demonstrated the ability
to scale to pretty massive levels in
fact GCS is just a layer on top of
Colossus which is the cluster level file
system that doesn't just handle the
storage needs of GCE VMs GCS content
serving etc but also handles all of
Google's internal storage needs from
search to Maps YouTube photos etc and
lastly we learned that there's a ton of
complexity under the covers of GCP but
systems like Colossus have abstracted
all of that away allowing GCP customers
to just focus on their business so to
wrap up I want to give a big thanks to
Dean for being my partner in crime for
this deep dive into what lies under the
hood of storage at TCP hey Dennis glad
to be that partner and thanks a ton for
sharing your extremely deep knowledge in
Colossus and Google Cloud storage and I
really hope this gives our customers
confidence that by using this skill
underlying scalable infrastructure that
they can scale their applications as big
as they're looking for thanks a lot I
hope you found this as interesting as we
do and that you learned a lot have a
great day